話しさせていただきました
挙手の方をお願いします
質問がある方はどうぞ
はい  あの 人生の選択っていうところがあって
その中で えーと 優先順位
優先順位の話であって
あの  2番目が娘 フォロー up だとか
3番目が社会や家族への要求に応じる
4番目が自分の科学の楽しみっていうのは
行為としてはよく理解できるんですけど
1番目の人目を乗り越えることっていうのがあったんですけれども
これはどういうふうなことで
行為としてどういうふうにやればいいんですかね
まあそれはまあ 煩悩をなくそうというね
まあ修行するしかないんですけどね
これはやっぱり じゃあ修行をしなさいっていうか
進めているという 受け止める
そうですね いわゆるヴィパッサナー瞑想
自己観察することが一番優先な仕事なんです
人の生命の本職であるなくてはならないのはそれなんです
他は本職じゃなくて ついでにやるもんなんです
それは普通の世界では認めませんだけど
一応心理の立場からそういう順位なんです
質問 どうぞ  あの目標ということでお聞きしたいんですけど
今まで今日の話よく分かったんですが
ベストを尽くすということで
大抵目標は何か設定してだと思うんですね
今のお話を聞いていると
ただ目標を立てるときっていうのは
計画とか記号化して欲が絡んだりとか
比較されたりすると思うんですよ
そのあまり良くないことなのかなと思うんですけど
例えば実現可能で 実現が可能で
充実感が得られれば そういったのも有利になる
それはまあ大体ね そんなもんです
実現可能で またその結果も悪くないという場合はね
そういう目的があって
目標があって それにまあ頑張るということは決して悪くはないんです
なんですけど 先ほど質問ありましたが
優先順位が優先順位がありますね
それで あの やっぱりその社会との軋轢というか
周りが理解を得られない時は
例えば瞑想だったりしても
それに対して批判的なことを言われたりとかするのもあるかと思うんですけど
それはやっぱり心を危険にすることにかなえば
やっぱり勇気を持って進む
だから 人の批判は気にしてはいけないってことをね
自分がしっかりヴィパッサナー瞑想やってて
そちら員の酔っ払いの人々を馬鹿にしてたんだからって
なんで酔っ払いの話聞くんですかね
だからその場合は勇気を持って
あんた方は何やと どうぞあなた方の世界で頑張ってくださいと
ということでね だから正しい道は堂々と勇気を持って歩まなくてはならないんでしょうしね
だから世の中で何か達成した人ならば
みんな世間の話を聞いてないんでしょうし
大体すごい世界でね 名前残ってる人々っていうのは
人の話を聞いてないんですよ
自分が決めたことはずっとやっているんです
だからまあ そういう現象も世の中にはあります
決して自分が瞑想しているんだからと会社
みんな喜んでくれるはずがないんです
みんなゴチャゴチャいろんな嫌味を言うならば
それが普通なんです  どうぞ
大変わかりやすい話でありがとうございます
先ほど一つのことに横柄でないで集中しなさいというお話をしました
それはそれでよくわかります
ただ一方で 仕事だけはいけないよ
家庭だけでもいけないですけど
それもよくわかります
ただ 集中することと他をバランスするということは矛盾のように
なるほど なるほど  そこら辺もわかり
はいはいはい  そこら辺ちょっと説明足らなかったと思います
で あの これ私は人生というのは流れだと言ったんですね
流れというのは何にストップなんですよ
だから今の 1 秒で 今の 1 分で自分の仕事はあるんでしょうし
それが終わったら次の 1 分の自分の仕事なんですよ
それに集中するって意味なんです
いわゆる一生集中するということなんですよ
だからこの 大体みんな忘れがちなのは
まあ仕事に集中すると言うと
他のことはなんかおろそかになっちゃうんですね
そういうことというよりも
この時間の流れをすごく気をつけるんです
だから 今の時間の小さなコマの中で自分が何をするのかと
それに集中する 例えばちょっと前
喋って質問したでしょうね
その場合は質問することに集中する
こう見たり あれ見たり
やっちゃうと正しく質問できない
今答えを聞いてる時ですね
それで聞いてることに集中するということで
だから 時間の流れによって
我々の仕事は瞬間瞬間変わっていくんでしょうし
その都度その都度集中していける
そうするといつでもベストを過ごしてるんです
それと矛盾にならない
会社では仕事に集中する
家に帰ったらそちらに集中するということ
よろしいですか？はい
先日の寺田高校の講義に伺っていただいたんですが
その時のお話の中で諦めるっていうことが出たように思うんですけれども
何か目標を持っていろいろ頑張って
それが達成されなかった時に
一つの結論として諦めるっていうことも大事な選択なのかなって
自分の中でそう解釈したりしたんですけれども
今日のお話の中では 諦めないことも大事って言ってたように思うんですけれども
どっちがっていうか どのようにこう
自分の人生の中で考えて
正しいことはこれなんですよ
だからすべて瞬間瞬間変わっていくんでしょうし
私はあの朝のテレビ番組からね
科学者たるものさえも過去に戻ろうとしてるんでしょうね
皆様方も視線は戻した方がいいと思ってるでしょうね
でも過去に戻せませんよ
世界はすーっと前もって前もって変化していくんでしょうし
だからこの諦めるか諦めないかということは
みんな過去に足を引っ張られて
もう終わったことでしょうに
現実離れになる 今の仕事はしなくなる
過去に何か不幸な出来事が起きちゃう
起きちゃうとそればっかり思いてしまって
自分の人生を台無しにする
だからその時点で過去だから私は忙しいんだと
今これやらなくちゃいけないんだという感じで
瞬間瞬間 その時の行為をして
仕事をして やることは完了して生きていると
常に幸福感 充実感を感じるんですよ
今幸福だったら 過去でちょこっと失敗があってもね
まあすぐとにこっと笑うことはできますよ
あ そうだそうだ そんなこともあったよと
だからこの過去に足が引っ張られないようにということで諦めるということがあるんです
いわゆるいくら踏ん張っても過去は戻せません
例えば女性の場合は 誰かと付き合っていて
また喧嘩して別れたんだと
やっぱり付き合ってたから気持ちよかったと
過去を戻したいけど戻せません
また仲直りしても過去じゃないんですよ
それまた失敗する なぜならば
過去に戻そうとしてるんだから
だからこの過去に戻そうとしないならばうまくいくんでしょうし
一旦喧嘩して別れた人でまた仲良くなったと
仲良くなった時点から新しい人生なんですよ
過去じゃないんです みんなこの過去を諦めて忘れてくれないんだから
結構失敗する だから答えは同じ
出来事は 2度と起こらない
2回は生きていられない
全て一回きりです この一回きりのことは成功しなくちゃいけないんです
だから今日の話でそれを言いたかったんです
だから 諦めないで踏ん張るっていうことでもないんです
とにかく踏ん張る 頑張るっていうことは
無常の流れで前へ進むことなんです
前進することなんです
前進する場合は いつでも過去を忘れなくちゃいけないんです
だから ちょこっと諦めてなくてもいいやと言ったのは
例えばちょこちょこと軽い目的があるとかね
ちょっとした軽い計画があるとかね
これ軽い 実行できる  実行もできて楽しいことだったら
そこら辺ちょこちょこっと無理をしたってもいいんじゃないかなと
でも無理をすることは人生ではありません
すごい危険です ちょっと無理をしたと
それで構いませんだけどね
山を登ったんだけど 頂上に 20 メートルぐらいあるところで
もうもう倒れてしまったということで
でもでももう悔しいと尺に障るとと言って無理をして登ってみる
それは大丈夫です でもそれで命がなくなるんだったらやめた方がいいんです
だから たまたまちょこっと無理をする
まあちょこっと踏ん張ってみるということは人間にもあります
しかし 人生は無理をするものじゃないんです
そういうことで 諦めるっていうことは
過去を諦めてしまう いつでも前向きで先進的であると
人生はね 一回きりやと
何でもね 世界することなんです
よろしいですか  はい 個人的なことなんですが
今私のいる職場についてなんですけれども
今私が働いているところが
皆さん多分ご存知な有名なタレント事務所なんですね
で この 5 月からちょっと転職していってまして
で 女性ばかりの職場でまだ男性が 1人いるんですが
8名の会社で 今ちょっと広告関係のことについて仕事をしているんですけども
女性の方たちがですね
非常に暴力的といいますか
ヒステリックな方たちばかりで
で 何かにつけてこう気に入らないことにつけては攻撃をしてくる
こういう人たちですね
で 中では一人 一番若い男性が特に攻撃されていじめられたりとかしてまして
で もちろん私に対しても
何かちょっと気に入らないことがあると非常に言ってくると
で 社内だけではなくて
外の人に対しても 電話で話す時ですとか
打ち合わせの時は非常にちょっと驚くような言葉遣いといいますか
ちょっとしたヤクザみたいな感じで喋り方をするんですけど
そういう人たちに対して注意のしようもないですし
自分もちょっとドキッとしてしまったりするので
それをちょっと自分自身はゆっくり観察しながらいたりもするんですが
誰か一人が攻撃の対象になったりとかしてる時に
どのようにそれを  どのようにやっても
それでまた大丈夫 2つでね
その人に何かしてあげることできるか
あるいは自分がどのような役割をするかっていうのをね
どちら聞きたいんですか？ 自分がどのようなアプローチを
病気だと思ってください
というか 病気ですからね
だから何か屁理屈なこと言って
まあまあ そちらからは別にそういうことはまあもう期待できませんので
という感じで なんとなく
なんとなくもう切るというね
まああんたなら一応そういうことでしょうとかね
わかる わかりきったような感じでね
あんたならまあ電話かけて
まあごちゃごちゃ教えるか言うでしょうね
そういう感じでもうあまり気にしない
病気っていうことでね
病気ですよ だからそれ逆に相手の方から見ればかわいそうですけど
被害者ですからね そういう性格を金にしているんだからね
結局は かわいそうです
思い切って別の場所に動いてもいいし
それともできるだけ我慢していた
自分が自分に楽な仕事だったら
あっちこっち移転する必要ないんで
仕事が楽だったらもうやってもいいし
こんなギャーギャーギャーギャー言うんだからといって
それはどうせどこにもあるんだからね
例えば農業やりたい人がいい畑
田んぼを見つけてね で
虫の声が嫌いだと 言っても東京に行くぞという話にならんでしょうに
農業やりたくてたまらん人は
田んぼを見つけたら たとえ虫の声があってもね
まあ気にしないことでしょうね
だから自分にとって仕事に能力あるだったら
まあ別に移転することは考えなくてもよろしいし
別なところだともっと仕事をベスト尽くせるなと思ったらね
それを変えたってもよろしいし
そういう気に入らないことを言われるということは
人間誰でもやっているしね
だからまあ相当病気だなと思った方がね
やりやすいと思います
ありがとうございます
...回向の礼をいたします
[咳]回向文 六方僧の三宝に大回向経師
回向の理 比丘の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって集まったこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖先 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして争いがなくなりますように
サッビーティヨー ヴィパッジャントゥ サッベローゴー ヴィナッサトゥ マーテー バワットワンテラーヨー スキーディーハー
ユコー バヴァー バワトゥ サッベマンゲラン ラッカントゥ サッベデーヴァター サッベブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッベダン
マヌバーヴェーナ サッベサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティバワントゥ テー アビワダナシーリッセ ニッチャンワッダーパチャイノー
チャッターロー ダンマーワッダンティー アユワンメー スカンバラン
では 長い時間本当にご苦労様です
ありがとうございます